nein nein nein es geht und herzlich
willkommen zur ersten folge minecraft
seit langer zeit um wieder reinzukommen
in die ganze minecraft china habe ich
heute was ausgeworfen zwar spiel bald
eine runde
es kann ich selbst ja wer kennt es nicht
vielleicht ein paar von euch noch
siemens es früh aus der schule bei mir
meistens immer gemacht das geht so eine
person sagt was um die andere person
oder viele andere person müssen es
nachmachen
heute sieht das so aus spiels kairos max
sachen und ich muss machen was er sagt
egal was es ist
das sei aber bitte nicht so etwas wie
prostituierte oder so aber nicht werden
nur äußerst dumme sachen sein
da ist ja hier mit mir zu tun hat mein
leben freunde führen ich würde sagen
dass du für die ganze folge ein bisschen
dumm us teams erstmal diesen wunderbaren
decke und drückst in sowie ein klopper
decke auf der nase kannst du das machen
auch da muss die ganze runde dabei sein
irgendwas seine abfällt
dann überlege ich meine strafe euro je
damit fangen wir schon mal an ich will
einfach keine waffe ich hab mir diese
blöde holz axe effekt ist ja aber nur
mit auch keine waffe in den kisten drin
das wundert mich weder im haus noch
minister nicht können wie im haus noch
einer der reichsten ja oder nein ich
glaube ich nur zwei kisten nicht so
richtig gut man richtig gut genau dafür
bist du hier max und wenn du dein
schwert geklappt hat dann kriegst du
noch mal eine überraschung aber nicht so
eine kacke wie hilft ein schwert weg
nach schlechte idee
machen wir nicht weg da hilft dann
wieder auf aber selbst dann wieder auch
ich mich sinnvoll und vor allem kann ich
selbst redet weiter
ja hallo welche richtung ich weiß es
nicht kann ich zuerst rheingold apfel
und geht auf die plattform nach links
dahin anderen dahinter okay jetzt kommt
mir leute erst geändert werden
ok oskani ich weiß es am besten so ich
habe keine ahnung doch einfach auf die
holzstämme recht bitte bitte bitte leute
alleine da und der der tür über gebaut
also geh nach rechts report oder hatte
sie aufgefordert
ich glaube nicht entscheidung ob da
einfach nicht hätte ist kein weg mehr
aber er ist noch in rente
ja ich hab namen gesehen wohl okay ich
hab namen gesehen
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß dass es mir
leicht ich habe mit freude machen junge
um ein trocken abgesperrt von weit ich
bin kein verdammtes glide war ich bin
manager und soziales leben haben aus dem
haus gehen gibt es nicht die wird nicht
alt geworden
jetzt siehst du endlich mal was
weiter das ist nicht dein ernst alter
ich find es schon angemessen
so erwarte ich mich hoch hey diana gar
nicht abgezogen
wobei doch es zieht nun die normalen
herzen sicher als ob einer caps oft
schon ab zieht wirtschafts nicht meister
muss ich mal ein kranich helmut jetzt
endlich meinen gegner und kämpfen ja
aber wo sind die so gute augen america
boa hat funktioniert kriege ich keinen
fall schauen
ich habe auch keine vetter vor dem busen
also doch ein 2
ja ok schon häufig schon ab wir holen
hier drüben freilich das finden junge
das ist einfach losfahren ich habe so
eine behinderte brille
es ist mal eine auszeit 54 spieler ja du
kannst du dort entscheiden ob eder
heftigen werde werde sich aber im kampf
weitet diese gabe im unterdessen die
kämpfe ich weiter
ich gehe ich rede nicht darüber wusste
hinterher
heute holt ihr sehr schön sehr schön
platt gelegtes todesangst wieder hoch
ganz china legt sie auf dem tisch
abgelegt sie selbst auf den tisch damit
der hund weiter
junge nie wieder weil ich gar nicht wo
alter fnl ich doch ja aber ich muss ein
bisschen schräg hoch da würde ich ich
konnte doch nicht sein gericht ich
konnte doch nicht hey hey wie nennt man
sagt hey hey wie nennt man den part von
gesetz
der am arm
wie hat man den park vom gesetz der
bestimmt wie man gegenstand darunter
lässt kann ich das so sagt er wird es
nicht
fast senkrecht ja wohin kann ich selbst
sieht die schlechtere lösung welche die
gold rüstung ja ok diana breaking trotz
wahrscheinlich schlechter oder einfach
anfang einfach nicht okay dass mir
einfach kämpfen hätte ihn ja
wahrscheinlich halte mich durch den
sound durchsetzt hörte ihn
ich muss ich muss aber sagen nein nein
nein nein
dass leute wenn ihr mehr kann ist es
wollt dann strahlst du die kommentare
aber bitte lasst